let me kind of ask uh
a weird maybe a difficult question part
of the
it has to do with i've been uh recently
reading a lot about world war ii i'm
currently reading a book i recommend for
people which is uh
uh as a jew it's been difficult to read
but uh
the horizon follows the third reich um
so let me
just ask about like the nature of genius
the nature of evil if we look at
somebody like
uh einstein we look at hitler
stalin modern day jeffrey epstein
just um folks who through their life
have done with einstein and works of
genius and with the others i mentioned
have done evil on this world
what do we think about that in a live
wired brain
like how do how do we think about these
extreme
people here's here's what i'd say this
is a very big and difficult question but
what i would say briefly on it is
um you know first of all i saw a cover
of time magazine some years ago
and it was a big you know sagittal slice
of the brain and it said something like
um what makes us good and evil and there
was a little spot pointing to it and
there's a picture of gandhi and there
was a little spot that was pointing to
hitler
and and these time magazine covers
always make me mad because
it's so goofy to think that we're gonna
find some spot in the brain or something
instead the interesting part is
because we're live wired we are
all about the world and the culture
around us
so somebody like adolf hitler got
all this positive feedback about what
was going on
and the crazier and crazier the ideas he
had he's like let's set up
death camps and murder a bunch of people
and so on
somehow he was getting positive feedback
from that
and all these other people they're all
you know spun each other up and you look
at anything like
i mean look at the you know um the the
cultural
uh revolution in china or the um
you know the russian revolution or
things like this where you look at these
things my god how do people all behave
like this but it's easy to see groups of
people
spinning themselves up in particular
ways where they all say well
would i have thought this was right in a
different circumstance i don't know but
fred thinks it's right and steve thinks
everyone around you seems to think it's
right and so um
part of the maybe downside of having a
live wired brain is that you can get
crowds of people doing things as a group
so it's interesting to you know we would
pinpoint hitler saying that's the evil
guy but in a sense
i think it was tolstoy you said the the
king becomes um
slave to the to the people in other
words
you know hitler was just a
representation of whatever was going on
with that
huge crowd that he was surrounded with
so
um so i only bring that up to
say that it's you know it's very
difficult to say
what it is about this person's brain or
that person's brain he obviously got
feedback for what he was doing
the other thing by the way about
what we often think of as being evil in
society is
my lab recently published some work on
in groups and out groups which is a very
important
part of this puzzle so it turns out that
we are very
we are very you know engineered
to care about in groups versus out
groups and this seems to be like a
really fundamental thing
so we did this experiment lab where we
brought people and we stick them in the
scanner
and we i don't know something if you
know this but uh we show them
on the hand sorry we showed them on the
screen six hands
and uh the computer boop goes around
randomly picks a hand and then you see
that hand gets stabbed with a syringe
needle
so actually see a syringe needle enter
the hand and come out
and it's really uh what that does is
that triggers
uh parts of the pain matrix this areas
in your brain that involved in feeling
physical pain now the interesting thing
is it's not your hand that was stabbed
so what you're seeing is is empathy this
is you
seeing someone else's hand get stabbed
you feel like oh god this is awful right
okay
um we contrast that by the way with
somebody's hand getting poked as a
q-tip which is you know looks visually
the same but it's um
you don't have that same level of
response now what we do is we label each
hand with a
with a one word label christian jewish
muslim
atheist scientologist hindu and now the
computer goes around picks a hand
stabs the hand and the question is how
much does your brain care
about all the people in your out group
versus the one label that happens to
match
you and it turns out for everybody
across all religions
they care much more about their ingroup
than their accurate and when i say they
care what i mean is
you get a bigger response from their
brain everything's the same it's the
same
hands it's just a one-word label
you care much more about your in-group
than your out-group and i wish this
weren't true but this is how
humans are i wonder how fundamental that
is or if it's a
it's the emergent thing about culture
like if we lived alone with like if it's
genetically built into the brain like
this
this longing for tribe so i'll so i'll
tell you we addressed that so here's
what we did there are two
[Music]
actually there are two other things we
did as part of this study that i think
matter for this point
one is so okay so we show that you have
a much bigger response by the way this
is not a cognitive thing it's a very low
level basic response to seeing pain in
somebody okay
great study by the way thanks thanks
what we did next is
we we next have it where we say okay the
year is 2025
and these three religions are now in a
war against these three religions and
it's all randomized right but what you
see is your thing
and you have two allies now against
these others
and now it happens over the course of
many trials you see everybody gets
stabbed at different times
and the question is do you care more
about your allies and the answer is yes
suddenly
people who a moment ago you didn't
really care when they got stabbed now
simply with this one word thing that
you're they're now your allies you care
more about them
but then what i wanted to do was look at
how ingrained is this or how arbitrary
is it so we brought new
participants in and we said here's a
coin toss the coin if it's heads you're
an augustinian if it's the tails you're
a justinian
these are totally made up okay so they
toss it
they get whatever we give them a a band
that says you know august indian on it
whatever
tribe they're in now and they get in the
scanner and
they see a thing on the screen that says
the augustinians and justinians are two
warring tribes then you see a bunch of
hands some are labeled augustine some
are justinian
and now you care more about whichever
team you're on than the other team even
though he's totally right and you know
his arbitrary because you're the one who
tossed the coin yeah so
it's it's a state that's very easy to
find ourselves in
in other words just before walking in
the door they'd never even heard of
augustinian versus justinian and now
their brain is representing it simply
because they're told they're on this
team
you know uh now i did my own personal
study of this
uh it's uh
so once you're an augustinian that tends
to be sticky because i've been a packers
fan
uh greenbed pakistan my whole life now
when i'm in boston
with like the the patriots it's been
tough going for my livewire brain to
switch to the patriots
to be so once you become it's as
interesting once
the tribe is sticky yeah but that's true
that's that's it you know you know we
never tried that about saying okay now
you're
adjusting the enemy we're in august how
how sticky it is but there are studies
of this
of monkey troops uh on some
island um and
what happens is they look at the way
monkeys behave when they're part of this
tribe and how they treat members of the
other tribe of monkeys
and then what they do i forgot how they
do the exactly but they end up
switching a monkey so he ends up in the
other troop and very quickly they end up
becoming a part of that other troop and
and hating and behaving badly towards
their original troop
these are fascinating studies by the way
yeah this is
beautiful
you